[Musique]
on le sait la période est
particulièrement difficile pour tous les
restaurateurs enfin pour tous ou presque
être car qu'on se le dise ce qui
participe à l'émission top chef sur m6
s'en tire plutôt bien
c'est le magazine public qui révèle le
salaire des membres du jury de
l'émission de m6 le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que la cuisine des
chefs des recettes ça c'est dangereux on
retrouve d'abord le père est qui pour sa
première participation à l'émission a
réussi à négocier le salaire de 35000
euros pour la saison
un joli pactole mais bien loin des 50
mille retouchée par michel sarran waouh
chasse et 10000 euros de moins qu hélène
darroze chef triplement étoilé qui a
réussi à faire monter les enchères à
60000 euros pour sa participation
c'est génial mais tout ça ce n'est rien
comparé aux maîtres des négociations
philippe etchebest le chef star d'm6 qui
en raison d'un juteux contrat
d'exclusivité avec la chaîne a quant à
lui reproché 85000 euros pour cette
nouvelle saison top chef paiement alors
êtes vous choqué par les salaires des
jurés top chef
alors je vais y assembler nom qui va
encore m'insulter mais je suis désolé
c'est très mal payés il a 14 ou 15 prime
ramener ça à l'émission il faut noter m6
a fait une très bonne affaire c'est les
quatre sont vraies ce sont de vraies
marques stars et on est sur des vrais
standards l'ordonnancé salaires pas
croyable mais des guillemets il ce qu'on
disait être chanteur sur une chaîne que
apparemment que chef parce que pour le
coup même si ça reste une somme
évidemment énorme je vous ramener ça à
l'émission et ramener sa hausse est la
moins de l'ensemble des gens qui font de
la télévision à 20h30 sur une chaîne a
encore une fois c'est pour moi c'est pas
bien payé j'aimerais avoir l'avis de
nicolas pernikoff parce que vous étiez
connaissez tous les salaires vous étiez
pas car il s'agit d auneau de 12 jours
de tournage sur 45 jours et tous les
intervenants extérieurs sont payés entre
3000 et 5000 euros sert les lie sa voix
qui vient de passer une journée enfin
ils n'apprennent là donc c'est son
palais c'est le moi ce qui me surprend
le plus c'est la différence de salaire
entre les chefs non mais c'est normal et
sûrs et c'est la star d'accord mais
quand même paul pairet attaque qui
rentre à 35000 étant donné qu'ils sont
montés parce que c'était pas le salaire
de départ ce sont les flyers s'est pas
d'année en année c'est un piège
s'assurer c'est franchement on peut
presser de le programmer richesse et la
notoriété des hommes qui tient sur la
notoriété des chefs c'est comme le jury
de the voice intentionnés mais c'est pas
grave
après hélène darroze si c'est très très
connu il ya chez le savant il est très
beau bien derrière paul peyry il vient
d'arriver il va m'aider je penserai qu'à
six mois
la brasserie du crayon et donc c'est
aussi quelqu'un qui est très petit et
très médiatisée aussi et enfin s'ils
fournissent une vraie expertise
alors j'ai bien 27 choqué oui parce
qu'en fait cette émission elle leur
permet de faire la promo de leur
restaurant est vrai que c'est une
affaire de principe c'est à dire que je
vais vous dire franchement il ne devrait
pas pour moi être payés parce que c'est
la promotion déguisée
vous l'aurez c'est de contenir tous les
toits laissez moi finir de six
restaurants comme ça il multiplie les
ouvertures parce qu'ils sont juré ses
mails ou de la promo et d'ailleurs il en
aura tout le temps de leur restaurant de
leur établissement donc moi je trouve
que quand c'est de la promo on n'est pas
payé sur un plateau ça n'est que mon
point de vue il faut moi qui courent
regarde l'émission je peux aussi on
parle pas de leur restaurant toutes les
limites en fait s'ils sont à l'arrêt en
ce moment mais là honnêtement il faut un
vrai boulot et tourne 12 heures par jour
7 points honnêtement la rive à mantoue
vrai qu'il le fasse rapidement wii sera
ouverte jusqu'au crash gate est choquée
s'est passé soient découverts vous faire
un film érotique en flèche et gratuite
moi c'est pas assez ils gagnent pas
assez topchef ça cartonne grâce à eux et
la particularité de topchef par rapport
aux autres émissions de divertissement
vous avez des soi-disant star s'est
classé des vraies stars de la cuisine
sert du lourd quoi oui quand ils ont dit
savoie en guest qui ajuste le meilleur
restaurant du monde qui prend 3 ou 4000
euros mais c'est une aubaine pour eux
c'est génial d'aller aux gens il devrait
gagner dix fois plus
alors c'est quand même aujourd'hui fois
mais les jambes mais en télé c'est dix
fois non et ça va être proportionnelle
au succès d'émissions top chef c'est un
carton ils doivent être payés et oui en
plus en ce moment les mauvais faillite
et chômage résonne pour les
restaurateurs hélène darroze assez
confié il ya quelques mois en disant
qu'elle était endetté jusqu'au cou elle
et qu'elle n'avait pas été de me voir
ici et là des finances il ya bien des
gens qui méritent en ce moment de gagner
c'est bien le seul à avoir eu et louis
s'en sort de top chef mais normal et
était sur la grande forêt les noms ils
donneront rien mais là latifa dit
excusez moi mais tout va vous répondre
tous les gens qui nous écoutent tiffany
voit ses salaires là il y en a qui
gagneront jamais ça on veut bien sûr on
ne dira ce n'est pas le nom mais
n'oubliez pas le smic en france
il discutait depuis mai pour tous les
gens qui nous regardent mais benjamin
hockey
et des salaires et yvan délirant et
vivre des gens c'est comparer ces autres
personnes qui sont à la télévision donc
envahi par catégories de métiers les
boulangers gagne la plus ou moins la
même chose et les gens de la télé il ya
à peu près dé certaines tranches et
c'est pour ça que là c'est choquant
parce que c'est beaucoup moins que par
exemple sur tf1 ou sur d'autres chaînes
et tu disais ils devraient être payées
moins parce qu'ils font de la promotion
ici le fait d'être ici on fait la
promotion pour notre personne peut-être
que benjamin vendra plus je lis moi ma
chambre quand mattel signe c'est une
très bonne idée je pense que nos
spectateurs tient très belle
intervention des filles oui à 33 % de 67
pour sur les